Rachel's with us in Houston Texas hi
Rachel how are you hi Dave I'm doing
great thank you for taking my call sure
what's up I just finished my graduate
program and I'm currently on a one-year
postdoctoral fellowship and I'm just
trying to strategize were paying off my
student loans I entered graduate school
with no debt but I'm out of graduate
school with 102 thousand nine hundred
and fifty-six dollars of debt and what
is your how much is your fellowship pay
for those for this year is I'm making
forty seven thousand seven hundred and
seventy one dollars and you finish that
you'll be doing what I am studying for
my life insurance I call it as a
psychologist okay but your PhD right yes
so I completed my PhD and I mean so
you're going to be a practicing
psychologist or psychiatrist
psychologist yes okay okay and so um
you'll get a license and so forth and go
through the process of practicing in
Texas correct okay go ahead and so I
have all of my data student loan debt
and I have no other debt about a little
over a hundred thousand of that is
Stanford loans a combination of
subsidized and unsubsidized and then I
have a just under two thousand of that
is graduate PLUS loan which is occurring
at a seven point nine percent interest
rate and I'm just wondering if I should
just go ahead and pay that off by the
end of this year and just kind of
sacrifice I have a goal of putting away
about 10k by the time my fellowship is
done by following a budget a very tight
one and I'm just thinking maybe I can
just go ahead and pay that graduate PLUS
loan law by the end of this year and
just kind of take that out of my goal
for the 10k that'd be fine is that your
smallest one that is my smallest why I
want you to pay off the smallest one
first and just begin to work your way
through this process
when you finish the fellowship what's
the purpose of the fellowship if you're
going into practice oh well if it's
usually just to accrue more our to be
eligible work for licensure or like the
thing oh okay that makes sense okay all
right
excited and I couldn't figure out how I
was going to make you more marketable
okay but that doesn't make sense for
licensing because you need you got to
have a certain number of hours and most
states to get that okay cool
so then you're going to open your own
practice or you're going to join a
practice or do you know well I work as a
VA the Veterans Affairs Medical Center
and I want to kind of stay within that
system because I enjoy working with the
veteran population and what was a baby
the pay would range depending on where I
would be in Texas but it would be
somewhere between 65 and just over 100k
okay perfect well just work that system
then and then what we're going to do is
just have no life and completely attack
this $93,000 it's left on your debt at
that point and if you do that as a
single person making 65 to 100 you ought
to be done with that in three years or
so so it sounds to me like but you're
gonna have no life during that three
years because you got to clean this mess
up that you've made and that's what we
would recommend focused intensity on
your debts that's the big deal hey guys
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video click the subscribe button to get
the latest content and check out these
other great clips from the show
[Music]